Elon musk's
cooperation and or
technical
relationships with other countries
uh
is worthy of being looked at
so Greg what was wrong with him I don't
know he's dying that was how long did it
take him to say six words he was
choosing his words carefully he didn't
know what he was saying he's saying you
got to look into foreign
you should look into somebody else's
foreign ties uh can you say Ukraine can
you say China are you out of your mind
he has no concept of what people do in
this world to make the world better he's
demonized individuals who do their jobs
he's stealing from American workers to
give to people who won't pay off their
loans he's cropped on so many people
because they don't vote for him he's
trying to go after somebody who's
expanding the freedom of speech he's
always on the wrong side of everything
but hey at least he's a nice guy and he
doesn't tweet no he's a liar no but he's
such a nice guy judge no he lied to them
I'm just saying he's a nice guy he's not
a nice guy lie to the Americans
so the reason that he's saying this is
because there's a Saudi prince in his
investment firm her now the two biggest
the number two biggest stakeholder in
Twitter we know that there was a Saudi
spy that was working at Twitter was
spying on dissidents
um we also know that Saudis obviously
were responsible for killing Jamal
khashoggi do you think this is that
insane what about the Chinese I mean
they're trying to take over in terms of
I think Tick Tock is a complete danger
to all of us yeah well you've got small
well and you've got fines you've got
you've got the Chinese infiltrating I
don't know what about Senator Dianne
Feinstein being investigated uh okay I
think what about this I think that this
do you want to answer this
yeah I I think the whole thing is Rich
it's just a totally Rich hypocrisy that
can only happen with this president who
hates anybody who's not a Democrat and
he's lied to the American people he said
he knows nothing about his son's
business stealings Tony bobolinski is
the only guy who came out the FBI
wouldn't interview anyone else you want
to talk about fraud you want to talk
about other governments they went
through Europe with a with a garbage bag
and a vacuum cleaner sucking up money
from all these people who have no
interest in America and being free Elon
Musk buys Twitter and people are now
worried oh my God the First Amendment
they're going they're not going to have
any any lockdown on First Amendment no I
have no problem with that with this
okay
um Dana the impersonating problem that
is happening on Twitter now we're
talking earlier about this Eli Lilly
tweet that was up it happened to LeBron
James and so I don't actually understand
what's going on on the blue check mark
thing but obviously that it needs some
fine tuning yeah and the I'm sure they
are working on it uh over at Twitter
because they've got to get a handle on
it and they've got to figure out a way
to make sure the advertisers stay Etc
how are they going to keep it going but
you know give them a minute I think as
he owned it for seven days or something
like that I think that things need to
settle down but I think he's the one to
do that I would point out that Joe Biden
seems to have something against Elon
Musk going way back do you guys remember
at the beginning of the administration
when they invited all the electric
vehicle manufacturers to the White House
but they wouldn't invite him and he sent
a letter and some people speculated it
was because he doesn't allow for
unionization at his plans and so Elon
Musk has been in the crosshairs of Joe
Biden for a long time and now he's a
convenient foil right that the best
thing for Joe Biden is always have
somebody to be fighting against to be
pushing against and a lot of people have
been going along with that
I don't know how this ends in terms of
the blue check mark or Twitter or
anything I I like it to for a lot of
reasons I'm excited about more people
being able to be on sharing their ideas
but I really don't know how they figure
out this blue check mark thing
especially with what is it 3 700 less
employees
um what do you have to say about there
is a Saudi spy working for Twitter
what about the Chinese spy that was
working for Hunter oh we're playing what
about game what about Donald Trump that
doesn't make any sense
[Laughter]
I'll tell you something about about this
this was a setup by Michael Bloomberg he
had a Bloomberg reporter remember
Michael Bloomberg is a billionaire
Democrat donor so a billionaire got a
guy to ask a Democrat president
do we think that this other
right-leaning billionaires a national
security threat and the Democrat
president said yeah let's investigate
him that was a setup and it stinks
that was little Michael Bloomberg right
there that was a direct hit little
Michael don't little
he's not little he is little but that he
is little to you especially I'm very
tall that's true he's a huge figure